for this video I wanted to put a bit of
a spotlight on dibella Ramsey since
she's doing a great job in The Last of
Us and I wanted to go back and analyze
what she did so well as lyanna Mormont
initially she was supposed to be a
one-off character and somehow she was
able to convince Steven and Dan to give
her more scenes and even a major one at
the end of season six along with
becoming a recurring character
afterwards this is a rare feat in shows
and essentially means that the actor was
so good to the point that they changed
the minds of the writers another example
of this was Jesse Pinkman in Breaking
Bad Jesse was supposed to die in season
1 but Vince Gilligan was convinced
through Aaron's performance that there
was something missing within the show
from there he became an integral
character and even ended up getting his
own spin-off movie now even though
lyanna Mormon isn't as important as
Jesse was Game of Thrones is an
inherently Big Show with dozens of
characters so it could have been really
easy for David nadan to have dropped her
and there wouldn't have been a Major
Impact so that means that you'd have to
be even more impressive to push past any
potential competition for screen time
for lyanna Mormont let's identify the
core internal and external reasons as to
why she turned out to be such a good
character starting out with the internal
Factor we have the performance of Bella
Ramsay Game of Thrones has had some
amazing Child Actors and I won't go so
far to say that Bella Ramsay is the best
but I think she stands out because of
how well she fits into the mold of
lyanna's badass persona it's really hard
for a child to command this much respect
and to be this bold and it could have
easily have not worked that's why to me
she's so distinct it must be why David
and Dan wanted to extend her presence
within the show but let's look
specifically at what Bella Ramsay does
to achieve this acting wise what sticks
out the most is her usage of inflection
and the volume of her voice Lord Kerwin
your father was skinned alive by Ramsay
Bolton
still you refuse to call she
intentionally puts a lot of emphasis on
certain words to further punctuate a
character beat along with using this
louder shift in volume to be more
commanding and to stand above the other
characters who are more hesitant to
speak louder it erupts her onto the
scene where she breaks the tradition of
making a bit of small talk and cutting
to the chase with why they are there I
think a clever thing that Brian cogman
does with the script was having lyanna
interrupt characters on multiple
occasions when she starts talking but
you have to understand my lady is this I
understand that I'm responsible for Bear
Island nor who live here so why should I
sacrifice one more moment life is
someone else's War it creates this brief
moment that catches the characters off
guard and immediately establishes that
we are playing by lyanna's rules she's
essentially in charge of this scene
another small moment that geniusly sets
up a more independent and intelligent
characteristic for lyanna is the fact
that she chooses to confide in her meser
for information but the second he
approaches her without approval she
waves him off just a very efficient bit
of writing and to be honest this is one
of those rare well-written scenes of the
later Seasons then there are even some
instances of subtle cinematography that
Aid the notion that lyanna is in charge
for this shot the composition places Jon
on the right side of the frame and
there's a lot of space behind him since
there is barely any room ahead of him it
gives off a claustrophobic presence in
front of him and it feels like he's
talking into a wall or there being
opposition ahead of him this breaks the
normal shot composition of having
leading room ahead of someone talking
and then the shot after this where it
cuts to a close-up of Jon as he's
speaking we assume that that we are
going to stay on the shot for a while
but we don't when lyanna interrupts them
and we quickly cut away so between these
two shots we break tradition and footage
to establish lyanna as being in control
now I said I was going to talk
specifically about Bella Ramsey's acting
but I think it's important to point out
the other aspects of production that
aider in this scene it all comes
together to make a strong introduction
for her character this scene may not
require a ton of range emotionally from
Bella Ramsay but that doesn't mean she's
incapable as especially shown in The
Last of Us where she goes through an
entire Gambit of emotions that she
effortlessly breezes through she
perfectly does the tasks she was given
in Game of Thrones and if anything does
an even better job than what was
expected she doesn't come off as trying
too hard to be intimidating and her
attitude in the scene is smart and
calculated as far as I understand you're
a snow and Lady Sandra is a Bolton who
is Lannister
I've heard conflicting reports she's not
being overly emotional and it feels like
everything she's saying has purpose and
even though she's interrupting
characters it never comes across as that
disrespectful because she is normally
the one prioritizing what should be
discussed in the conversation and is
smart enough to see that this attempt at
small talk is futile looking at her
final scene of season six she gives a
rousing speech that leads into the
climax of Jon's entire season Arc like
that's honestly an insane upgrade from
being a one-off character to one that
has to build up the hype to announce Jon
Snow as being King of the North and I
think she Nails this scene really well
again her usage of inflection is very
particular and detailed but I also love
how she pauses between some of her lines
it creates a sense of dramatic build up
for her delivery to have even more of a
punch when she's calling out different
Lords for not showing up to the battle
of the bastards you for allegiance to
have start Lord clover but in their hour
of greatest need
you refuse to call then the writing AIDS
her acting because she's able to
escalate a recurring phrase throughout
the scene it's as if she's embodying a
Viper as she strikes down each one of
her victims and then she caps off the
moment with a triumphant approval of Jon
Snow in season 8 we have the mirror of
the scene which is kind of a nice moment
but it feels a little cheap that David
and Dan are essentially copying this
moment from season six but it's in
Reverse along with it being pretty
unreasonable that the north is mad at
him for leaving temporarily to get
reinforcements to fight the night King
which was completely necessary but going
into all that would be getting off topic
Bella Ramsay's acting has well-timed
character beats is able to Captivate an
entire room of people with her
commanding voice and she's able to come
across as simultaneously intelligent and
giving off a crazy amount of confidence
that really shouldn't be possible for a
child to portray and the fact that a
child actor is able to achieve all of
this and so much more is extremely
impressive of so I think she perfectly
executes the character lyanna Mormont
from an acting standpoint looking at the
more external reasons for why lyanna
Mormon is a good character there are
quite a few firstly I think one of the
most important factors is that she
symbolizes what the later Seasons lack
so much which are more new characters
David and Dan in general for the later
Seasons wanted to minimize new
characters and focused primarily on the
pre-existing ones instead of committing
to a 10 season goal that George and HBO
wanted David and Dan opted to rush
through the Finish Line with eight
seasons that were also a shortened an
example of them not introducing new
characters is them reducing plot lines
in Dorne and the iron islands for those
two areas there were much bigger
conflicts within the books that also
brought about more characters like it
would have been much cooler if we saw
more greyjoys than the iron islands that
euron could kill to make him more
intimidating this all highlights a core
issue within the later seasons of Game
of Thrones in which instead of retaining
the big scale of Western Rose David and
Dan subtly reduced it by not making more
additions so this makes the inclusion
and high quality of lyanna Mormont that
much more important because she's a
representation of the expansion within
the world that should have been more
abundance from the characters they did
add lyanna Mormon is the best in my
opinion now you think that wouldn't be
the case but try to think about what new
characters David and Dan added in season
6 7 and 8 who were better you basically
just have euron Greyjoy lady crane
Randall tarly dick on tarly
archmaster ebros rabbit Glover and the
most important character Captain
Strickland
between these characters the only one
that really stands out is Randall tarly
and you can make the case for liking him
more than lyanna because of his
complicated relationship with Samwell
but I still like lyanna more because she
has more to offer in comparison lyanna
is essentially a Gateway into US seeing
more of the world of Westeros we've
never been to Bear Island before and
house Mormon is pretty important
considering that sir Jor and your more
months play big roles in the overall
story this is the content that should be
elaborated on show us more Northern
houses and flush everyone out especially
on each side of the coin because looking
at the Battle of the bastards John Umber
and Harold karstark were basically
background characters who had minuscule
character work it's just wild to me that
lyanna Mormont is one of the only new
characters that has tangible personality
traits and is tied in with the plots
like even Lord Glover who I thought had
some good scenes in season 6 ended up
getting tossed into the bin for season
8. he apparently doesn't show up and
there are no consequences for that since
it's never Revisited unless if the night
King attacked him first but if the night
King hit every northern kingdom north of
Winterfell then that would have taken
ages so it sucks how David and Dan are
shrinking the size of the cast and
Robert Glover could have easily been a
character to pad out the deaths for the
long nights when you look at the earlier
seasons of the show you had a much
better roster of characters and they
also made massive decisions that
affected the story an example being
Rickard karstark murdering some
Lannister boys that then prompted Rob
Stark to execute him which then
alienated the car Stark Army and that
even leads into Robb Stark having to
stoop so low as to ask help from the
phrase like would you look at that
characters making big choices that
drastically impact what happens lyanna
doesn't really have any major decisions
and is mostly along for the ride but at
least her character achieves the bare
minimum for some form of representation
of the north she's entertaining not just
because of Bella Ramsey's captivating
performance but because it gives you a
small
ounce of expansion for the north if we
had her and like three other prominent
Northern Lords then hey maybe we'd be
able to have more engaging dialogue
scenes within Winterfell similar to the
scene where lyanna is talking to Sergio
Mormons another reason why Bella Ramsay
works so well is lyanna Mormont was the
irony of her stature power bravery and
pure Big Balls as a kid in comparison to
the other grizzled and battle-hardened
characters of the North she blew them
away in terms of her chad-like energy it
made her shutting down these seemingly
tough individuals that much more
satisfying and boosted her up as being
more likable it basically set her
character up as being inherently
entertaining from a writing standpoint
and then Bella Ramsey took that
character and brought it to life with
great expertise and I also love how
she's not afraid to get her hands dirty
and wants to become a warrior it further
gives off an angle of feministic
empowerment because if this little girl
is ready to fight and isn't scared then
surely you should not be it's also
interesting how David and Dan made a
more obvious version of this notion with
this random extra girl wanting to fight
after this guy was scared to fight it
kind of bashes this message into your
face and I think it worked perfectly
well through lyanna Mormont as a
character and they didn't need to spell
it out for the audience not to mention
this girl doesn't show up again so this
feels like a deleted scene and the point
they're making here is made very clear
in the next episode through lyanna
Mormont taking down a giant lyanna has
one of the most badass death scenes in
the entire show because of this and this
is really the only good moment in the
entirety of the long night because it's
the irony of the smallest character
Bringing Down the biggest opponent on
the battlefield although it's
questionable as to why this giant would
pick up lyanna and start her like this
but whatever it makes for a good moment
if you don't question anything so in
essence I think her character is
inherently likable because of how much
she embodies a warrior which is also a
common Trend in Game of Thrones like
through Brienne of Tarth and Arya Stark
however it's just as commendable and
lyanna because of how much younger she
is for the last external factor that
benefits Leona Mormons she offers a good
contrast in comparison to the other
child characters for those child
characters we have Joffrey who is a mad
and unhinged brats Sansa who is in
constant turmoil and very slowly over
time learns the nature of politicking
bran was a curious Adventurer turned
into a depressed child who finally finds
purpose in life Arya who is similar to
lyanna and that she wants to be a
warrior but she has a gaping hole in her
heart as she looks for people to bond to
lyanna is the most adult-like child out
of this bunch and seeing these qualities
within a child is rare making her
leadership qualities and other confident
aspects tied to her character that much
more fun to watch she doesn't feel like
a redundant character because of this
and she is able to offer a unique
perspective in the already massive world
of Game of Thrones to me lyanna Mormont
is one of the only new characters past
season 5 that isn't written poorly the
fact that Bella Ramsay was able to
succeed so well at being a compelling
and mature kid who comes across as a
leader was impressive I'll also do a
video on Oberyn Martell since Petra
Pascal also happens to be in The Last of
Us in hindsight I probably should have
started with him since he's a more
popular character but I'll get to it
thank you for watching as always and
have a good day
foreign